steeve laurent blanc tout le monde le
connaît l'international joueurs à
montpellier hérault a reçu les jeunes
footballeur d'euros sont dans le gard et
en a profité pour effectuer lui aussi un
retour aux sources
tous les jeunes footballeurs du village
gardois de roussent se sont déplacés
récemment à montpellier pour assister à
l'entraînement de l'enfant du pays
laurent blanc un retour aux sources très
apprécié par la vedette de montpellier
vous êtes aujourd'hui entouré de d'une
flopée de jeunes de votre ancien club
que ça vous fait dans le sentiment ça
fait plaisir mais bon comme je disais
certains certains je ne connais pas et
comme je disais c'était c'est la relève
un petit peu de mon village en village
est en pleine expansion ça fait que de
voir tous ces jeunes ça prouve que le
village je n'ai pas moi et que ça fait
plaisir de les recevoir montpellier
j'espère qu'on allait recevoir la
meilleure façon possible en a beaucoup
je suppose qu'ils font du football
peut-être tout d'ailleurs ah oui c'est
cela c'est qu'ils font du football est
vraiment tout au moins qu'ils aiment le
football alors quels conseils vous leur
donnerez un petit peu parce que pour
vous êtes un petit peu un euro pour vous
êtes quelqu'un qui est arrivé au sommet
alors je crois qu'ils ont le temps de
s'amuser encore ligue de football puis 6
et s'ils veulent en faire leur métier
d'homme le temps d'y penser mais je
crois que pour l'instant pour eux c'est
un jeu le football et c'est très bien
comme ça vous savez garder vos racines
je suppose je suis un petit peu ce qui
se passe dans votre région ben oui
puisque pour cause de toute ma famille
habite encore là dans la région d'alès à
rousson donc bon
j'y revienne le plus souvent possible de
malheureusement c'est pas assez souvent
mon avis mais bon dès que je peux je
vais les voir jouer un petit peu et
j'espère qu'il y en a quelques-uns qui
sortiront qui font peut-être de du
footballeur métier justement quelles
qualités je dirais s'il devait y avoir
qu'une seule qualité qu'il faudra voir
pour en faire son métier qu'est ce
qu'elles qu'elles seraient et elle a
cette qualité il faut que le football
sur leurs patients qu'ils soient prêts à
tout sacrifier pour le football et puis
à ce moment là s'ils ont des qualités
avec moins de chasse ils ont la chance
de réussir voilà je souhaite à des
revenus 1 face à la caméra voilà
peut-être que demain on verra certains
de ses jeunes joueurs jouer au sein de
montpellier hérault en division une